am wochenende gingen zehntausende
menschen auch in deutschland auf die
straße gegen rassismus jetzt stellt sich
natürlich die frage gibt dass die korona
wählen den mundschutz trugen die meisten
von sicherheitsabstand war aber eher
nicht die rede
wir sprechen jetzt mit schauspielerinnen
annabelle mandeng sie war auch am wochen
annabelle mandeng sie war auch am
wochenende in berlin auf einer
demonstration und gestern konnte meine
kollegin sie ihn als den hof mit ihr
sprechen wir schauen da mal rein
frau man denken wie haben sie die
demonstration in berlin erlebte am
sonnabend
ich bin sehr froh dass die demonstration
hier sehr friedlich vonstattenging also
es war eine sehr aufgeräumte stimmung es
war ein sehr gut organisiert die reden
waren hoch emotional aber inhaltlich hat
auch sehr fundiert
und ich hatte das gefühl dass die leute
auch sehr froh waren dass ihnen dieses
forum
endlich hatten und das auch vor allen
dingen die unterschiedlichsten
hautfarben zusammen kamen die
unterschiedlichen entnehmen zusammenkam
es ging darum zu zeigen dass hier alle
eben zusammengehören und wir alle dieses
problem rassismus gemeinsam angehen
müssen und das hat in berlin super
geklappt was würden wir sagen wie
alltäglich ist rassismus immer noch im
alltag was erleben sie zb also rassismus
ist leider nicht aus dem alltag
wegzudenken also das ist
bedauerlicherweise auch dass wir in
deutschland ist oder in den restlichen
europäischen ländern oder natürlich in
den usa in afrika genauso ich habe als
kind in bad zwischenahn auch rassismus
erlebt und dann kann er in ganz kleinen
dingen stattfinden der kann der stadt
finden dass jemand mich an fast
ungefragt und halt sagt oder eine haut
ist so schokoladig oder ich kenn dich
ein und wird gesagt er kriegt doch
keinen sonnenbrand oder wo kommst du
denn her und wenn wir diese aus
norddeutschland ja aber ursprüngen nicht
natürlich kann man diese fragen auch
stellen aber es ist letztendlich
übergriffig und wenn ich gefragt werde
was die herkunftsländer meiner eltern
sind ist das eine andere frage
als mich zu fragen wo ich denn bitte
schön hätte ursprünglich von den kommen
aus deutschland in göttingen geboren ich
lebe hier bin hier aufgewachsen und so
geht es eben halt auch für die meisten
von denjenigen die auch afrodeutsche
sind oder die aus andere ethnische
hintergründe haben also es ist diese die
gesellschaft hat sich verändert wir sind
nicht mehr nur noch blond und weiß so
ist es nun mal
was kann eigentlich jeder tun also ihrer
meinung nach um das wieder ein stück zu
verbessern dass wir alle besser
miteinander leben können
also ich bin eine person die immer schon
für bildung plädiert hat ich habe einige
jahre meiner kindheit in thurow
verbracht durch die auslandstätigkeit
meiner mutter und auch in pakistan was
natürlich auch schon kontrovers an und
für sich ist und es geht letztendlich
glaube ich immer darum dass man durch
bildung man nun wissenschaft und durch
wissen
spa renz und die transparenz sorgt dafür
dass man sich besser kennenlernen und
dementsprechend auf ängste abgebaut
werden denn ängste sind oftmals ist die
basis für hass oder der grund sogar dass
man einander nicht versteht
und deswegen ist ein aufeinanderzugehen
und einen voneinander lernen das ist das
allerwichtigste damit eben nicht diese
ablehnung stattfindet damit man merkt
dass wir uns alle gegenseitig bereichern
also das ist ja auch wirtschaftlich
betrachtet nachweis nicht so dass eine
eine firma die die werks durchwachsen
ist dass die wesentlich stärker und
nachhaltiger wächst als ohne also man
muss sich auch einfach dass man
intellektuell begreiflich machen wie
viel diversität wie viel positives
diversität mit sich bringt und das
wissen die meisten glaube ich nicht und
wie war das auf der demonstration wir
haben gerade eben ihre bilder gesehen
sie haben sehr vorbildlich mund nasen
schutz getragen weil das bei allen so
und konnten dort auch die abstandsregeln
eingehalten werden bei 15.000 menschen
auf dem alexanderplatz die
abstandsregeln konnten in dieser form
nicht eingehalten werde sieht man beim
einem bild das hat man vor dem
bildschirm forschungen gesehen und auch
natürlich in anderen städten
es liegt glaube ich einfach daran dass
die brisanz des themas ist extrem hoch
und es ist natürlich kein neues thema
aber ausgelöst durch das video über die
misshandlungen von george iv leute sind
in die menschen auf die straßen geströmt
und das ist auch ein ganz wichtiges
anliegen der gesellschaft unter
bedingungen die derzeit in der korona
virus bedingungen haben wird das video
jetzt gezeigt genauer als ihnen die luft
weg gedrückt wird ein kran bri
unter diesen bedingungen haben glaube
ich die demonstranten das beste draus
gemacht und auch die organisatoren
nämlich darauf hinzuweisen dass bitte
alle eine maske tragen damit wir uns
nahe sein können es hat unter freien
himmel stattgefunden
ich habe vorhin noch einen arzt befragt
das war das waren die unter diesen
umständen besten bedingungen die man nun
mal in diesem fall treffen konnte und
das ist einige gibt wie die maske auch
mal abgesetzt haben oder eventuell gar
keine getragen haben das liegt einfach
daran dass es in allen menschen
gruppierungen solchen gibt gemeinden
dass sie über vernünftige maß an
hinwegsetzen müssen aber das gros hat
sich daran gehalten hat dafür gesorgt
dass diese demonstration eben ein ganz
wichtiges zeichen gesetzt